hey everybody it's Mike Freer here with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
au.l2-3.3.5 correlate audit record
review analysis and Reporting processes
for investigation and response to
indications of unlawful unauthorized
suspicious or unusual activity
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so uh I call this one the police
control all right so in cmfcc control
au.l1-3.3.5 correlate audit record
review analysis and Reporting processes
for investigation and response into uh
to indications of unlawful unauthorized
suspicious or unusual activity in other
words do you know when it's time to call
the police so here what we're doing is
we're getting into essentially the
intersection of where the seam or
security information in event management
and other monitoring and alerting
systems take shape and interact with
people in your organization as you will
see by what the assessors are looking
for in just a minute this control has a
mandated progression from what happens
in the system to how things are
responded to so if you're not sure how
you would really get that from the exact
wording of the control but hey that's
why we sort of punch through and are
delivering these controls from an
assessment perspective when it comes to
cmmc that way we can sort of show you
what the answer is and then you'll be
able to understand why they're asking
the question the way they are so let's
dive in let's check out what are the
assessors looking for and how to make
them happy on this one so again on au.l
2-3.3.5 there's really only two things
they're looking for the first thing
you're looking for is they want to
determine if audit record review
analysis and Reporting processes for
investigation in response to indications
of unlawful unauthorized suspicious or
unusual activity are defined so let's
take out all the garbage cook in the
middle determine if audit record review
yada yada are they defined if we were
going to give a sample answer that we
might say something to the extent of hey
look yes it's defined it's defined
within the seam solution right because
again you're gonna have policies and
templates within your seam solution as
far as what it should be actually
reporting on uh and of course there's
also an incident response plan where
you're also defining exactly how you're
going to record and then of course
respond to things so again those are two
places that an assessor would be looking
now if I'm looking at the second part of
the assessment criteria determine if
defined audit record review analysis and
Reporting processes are correlated again
there we can just look right back maybe
over the shoulder Surf and see that our
seam system is doing it so again we can
say we were implemented through our seam
or security information event management
solution and of course our incident
response plan
defines exactly how we're supposed to
execute on the usage of these tools so
if you're as confused as most people are
whenever they initially read that
control it might be time to give us a
call because an on-call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff drops into their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating Gap apps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmfc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliances roll
it out until the next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below let us know
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign